comment savez-vous d'accord c'est nous allons
vous tester maintenant c'est le test
quelle est la date d'aujourd'hui ouais en quelle année il
était un grand enfant il était un grand enfant il
aimait aller vite il dès que j'étais assez vieux
pour m'accrocher  J'étais sur la piste de
son grand puits avec eux pour la balade
de ma vie ce gars a tiré le meilleur
parti de chaque minute
qu'il a vécu cinq vies l'
équilibre hippie armé d'opposés vous savez un
amoureux et un combattant il n'est certainement pas
un  marionnette tu sais qu'il n'est certainement pas
quelqu'un à qui on va juste dire de faire
quelque chose et ensuite le faire le
cinéma n'a pas tout capturé ne pouvait pas
tout capturer Paul a toujours été un acteur
qui avait un pied dedans et un pied
dehors  Je disais toujours comme si je voulais être
garde forestier, vous savez, gagner 28 000 $ par
an et vivre dans la nature,
c'est vraiment ce qu'il voulait faire, ma
fille, mon surf, c'est la vie et
c'est ce qui m'importe, je peux
dire qu'il  fait beaucoup de choses qui ont fait
beaucoup de différence dans un  beaucoup de vies de gens
vous savez qu'elle était généreuse si vous l'
aimiez comme nous l'aimions vous diriez
bien pourquoi lui et pas nous
[Applaudissements]
vous